oui
[Rires]
i
j'étais pas du tout en train de forcer
pour faire caca j'étais en train de
faire ça parce que je vous rappelle que
c'est vous qui décidez d'une semaine à
l'autre qu'elle a trop je vais faire et
vous pouvez proposer la mode dans les
commentaires nous sommes mercredi les
six heures du matin c'est un jour de
castets comme chaque mercredi à 6 heures
pour le moment je ne sais pas si ça va
durer comme ça
et des fois il ya des vidéos bonus sur
le mentalisme le reste de la semaine et
en général c'est six heures pour ça vous
pouvez activer la cloche aujourd'hui on
va se faire free will be alors oui lycée
qui willis est elle cette petite bille
que vous voyez peut-être au fond de la
cage qui est complètement prisonnier il
va falloir la sortir voilà c'est tout ce
que je sais sur ce casse tête
on va passer à la phase de découverte
dans quelques instants et surtout aussi
de le résoudre
en espérant que ce soit plus rapide que
le casse-tête ya quinze jours n'en parle
plus
concernant les dates de spectacles comme
chaque semaine je voulais dit cette
semaine je suis à toulon et juste ce
mois ci en moselle 1 marseille également
à dijon vous allez le lire dans la
description faire toutes les dates de la
tournée
ok alors pris oui et willis et cette
petite boîte que vous voyez extrêmement
bien par la caméra du dessus vous la
voyez peut-être un petit peu mieux la
voilà et nous avons notre petit willy
qui est prisonnier jusqu'ici les libres
de bouger dans sa prison
donc voilà de quoi est composée la boîte
je vous explique bien ce que je vois pas
ce que c'est très dur déjà avoir à
l'oeil et on ne peut pas faire entrer
une caméra dans la prison mais grosso
modo il ya une planche centrale qui
découpe deux espaces elle est composée
de deux trous mais en diagonale et d'une
espèce de petit rainures trop et qu'un
point un peu plus gros trou et aussi au
bout ici il ya toute une partie cachée
qu'on n'arrive pas à voir et au dessus
un trou ont clairement c'est par là que
ça doit sortir titre est au dessus du
trou je vois comme une potence et sous
cette potence ya un petit truc
métallique que je soupçonne être un des
membres est en fait j'ai envie de
vérifier si j'ai raison ou pas est-ce
que tu peux me passer
une trombone s'il te plaît - trombone
vient ou une trombone je sais pas par
contre 10,1 écroué le 10 voilà bon bah
c'est clairement un aimant le casse tête
est résolu merci le hic leur frère d'un
frère je sers tu es le seul à avoir un
claudique personnes a applaudi de chez
lui bon ok si pendant j'ai l'impression
d'avoir réussi à ce que dément est assez
fort pour les conducteurs âgés un petit
peu oui voilà bienvenue sur la chaîne je
construis des figurants la partie cachée
remplit très bien sa fonction première à
savoir cacher je ne vois pas ce qui se
passe de l'autre côté est donc je fais
tomber la bille dans le trou et elle
tombe dans la partie cachée que vous
voyez là même moi je la vois plus donc
elle peut aller dans une complète
liberté de mouvement dans ce sens là ça
serait la clenche comme ceux ci par
contre gauche droite c'est très limité
donc en fait ça doit faire un couloir
papier crayon création alors comment ça
marche
500000 gigawatts dont la partie cash et
je pense que si on pouvait la voir
ça doit faire quelque chose un peu comme
ça mais alors ça c'est le no man's land
entre les deux donc la bielle tombe soit
ici elle peut bouger comme ça soit ici
elle peut bouger comme ça m'angoisse à
loïc
oui super et au centre je sais pas trop
ce qui est plein ce qui est pas plaint
mais duke le trou de la partie
supérieure se trouve ici je pense qu'ils
font là il va mettre la bbc pour qu'elle
soit saisie par léman au dessus ok
alors comment faire ça passe en fait ce
qui se passe chez les postiers cette
partie là je vais vous la dessiner de
comment je la vois moi mais donc là on a
de ce côté là c'est les barreaux et de
ce côté-là aussi kaka 4 crack est donc
là on a un trou un trou et là ça fait
une petite réunion avec un petit point
comme ça
donc comme je suis pas que ben est déjà
réfléchi je pense que la vie il faut
aller la place est ici parce que ça ça
correspond vraiment c'est complètement
aligné avec ce trou là de sortie finale
donc la place ici je vois comment faire
mais par contre après comment faire pour
qu'elle passe de là à l'appui à leyment
je pense vraiment que sur la théorie on
a résolu casse tête
et quand je dis on je dis moi parce que
vraiment à part applaudir c'est parti
pour les gosses et hyper valorisant mais
quand tu aimes dead ce n'est pas du tout
précieux loïc alors titre non le mythe
générique de fin le générique de fin
là encore donc j'ai essayé de la
positionner sur l'appliqué mire un
[ __ ] alors là je comprend par exemple
pourquoi les trous sont en diagonale
c'est pourquoi pour bien me faire chier
c'est juste pour ça ok là c'est sûr la
rainure
et là c'est dans le trou generic titre
donc là clairement j'ai réussi à mettre
la wii lit donc la petite bille à cet
endroit là là je les place et l'a donc
en fait je les fais monter ici et je les
fais après des 110 6 ans qu'elle retombe
la houle a donc à l'exposition équilibre
ici comment maintenant faire sauter
l'ensemble pour que ça passe par le trou
du dessus là et je suppose que la big et
en fer avec l emmental imagine celles en
plastique qui s'est jetée est ce que
j'essayais de faire un coup sec de com
comme une grosse chute comme ça ça ça a
rien fait mais la vie est toujours mais
moins remplies oh [ __ ] je tue des
casse-têtes moi ok c'est qui c'est moi
ou c'est pas encore j'ai envie de voir
plus mais avec robin comme si vous étiez
plusieurs ou alors tu fais comme ça donc
là qui est là et donc de pouvoir la
récupérer comme ça maintenant j'imagine
mais attends je vous la chope et quand
même
oui elle est là beaucoup trop cool mais
ça fait combien de temps qu'on est
dessus avec 35 100 non non tout 8 15 8
15 c'est à dire qu'il faut parler encore
de minutes
c'est incroyable n'a pas bien manger
pour bien faire voir des belles images
de ce casse tête
oui alors les casquettes font souvent
plus de dix minutes c'est pas de ma
faute c'est presque ça prend du temps et
qu'en sa fin en dessous je vous cache
pas que ça m'embête un peu parce que si
vous regardez les prix des casquettes
sur internet vous voyez que je ne veux
pas de votre gueule en fait zéro
partenariat à chaque fois que j'achète
des caches des casse tête
un peu cher donc là ça fait plus de dix
minutes c'est plutôt sympa en fait pour
essayer de financer ces casse tête mais
mais là ça fait moins ok beaucoup trop
cool avec vous la remettre dedans et ce
casse tête
je vous le fais gagner vous le savez
maintenant je les garde fous même ce que
je trouve cool et tout parce que ça me
prend beaucoup trop de place donc je
vous le fais gagner sur instagram vous
avez le lien ici mon instagram c'est
celui ci vous allez voir cette photo là
précisément et d'un vous commenter cette
photo il ya un hashtag hammett et puis
toutes les semaines je fais un tirage au
sort au bout d'une semaine et je voulais
fait gagner voilà voilà
que dire de ce casse tête sinon qu'il
était jolie qu'il était assez drôle à
faire mais c'est plus un truc d'agilité
parce que
franchement est-ce comprend assez vite
je sais pas si tout le monde le comprend
assez vite mais je pense que oui je vais
essayer de leur faire au moins une fois
pour montrer que ce n'était pas du
hasard
j'ai fait comme ça comme quoi certains
je ne quitterai pas la vidéo tant que je
n'aurais pas fait le deuxième fois c'est
important c'est à dire expliqué africain
j'étais plus agile donc là voilà j'en
suis là et je l'avais fait tomber en
mode tout c'est comme ça [ __ ] pourquoi
je me suis auto donné un défi
[Musique]
la page hors jeu parce qu'en fait vous y
arrivez encore une fois parce que clis
et loïc je sais que tu as encore en
vigueur que dire non mais non j'y suis
pas là encore bien parallèles
mais si la trousse c'était pas ça la
bonne méthode il ya un autre truc à
faire et est en fait j'ai juste que la
turquie est ce qu'on appelle un bail de
chasse en casse-tête c'est à dire un
truc qui fonctionne mais c'est pas censé
être puis quoi je ne sais déjà pu le
faire ah non rester avec moi j'ai un
truc important à vous dire à la fin donc
oui c'est pas une blague c'est vraiment
un truc que j'ai pas une pub c'est pas
une promo c'est rien c'est un truc pour
vous c'est extrêmement important et je
vous le dirais que quand je l'aurai
réussi une deuxième fois et j'espère
vous le dire parce que si je réussis
peine deuxième fois jeudi le dirigeant
[Musique]
j'arrive plus à le remettre sur trois
centrales
tu sais pourquoi parce que ça m'agace le
fric important en vigueur la fin je vais
vous dire qu'à la toute fin
là pendant que je vous parle vous avez
le lien d'abonnement qui apparaît la
vidéo de la semaine dernière c'était la
zbox qu'on a résolues avec le vintage
tran le truc important
ces rendez vous plus tard mercredi
prochain à 6h et et je vous aime c'est
ça l'important parce que c'est beau
l'amour ciao